from across the pond at the evian
championship over in france it's golf
digest's own hallie ledbetter
thanks for joining the show uh we were
having ben
well first of all we were supposed to
play golf ourselves this weekend we had
a tee time set up on saturday and then i
got the text message
oh i gotta go to france yeah
it turns out it takes a lot longer to
get here than i thought
so i thought you know it's like a day
trip you know no it's about uh it's
about a 20 hour journey
so so you you were watching you were
watching colin do his thing yesterday
uh in sort of a more normal hours and
the rest of us here stateside what were
your thoughts about seeing
this young star uh take his second major
championship
it was absolutely incredible then first
of all i will say i've never watched a
golf broadcast in french highly
recommend if you get the chance
very fun i really love when they say
robert mcintyre
it's really fun to hear the accent um
but it was it was it was incredible i
mean
i think i tweeted yesterday about how
nice
of nice of a person calling it i've had
the opportunity to work with him a few
times and
you know most of the guys on tour are
nice guys they're solid dudes
but colin is just on another level when
it comes to his humility and his respect
and how um how just great he makes you
feel he's such a wonderful person to be
around and it's
so um you know heartwarming to say the
least to see somebody who's such a nice
person
have so much success i mean for him to
win
two majors in his first two appearances
like the pga
first time there open championship first
time there he didn't play too great at
the scottish open last week he said it
was
you know a really good thing that he
played though because he was able to
figure out the grass and sort of how
link golf works so uh that was a good
decision i'm sure a lot of guys
you know will look at that going forward
with their ever hesitant on playing in
the scottish open and
sort of uh take that advice but it was
really great i'm so so happy for calling
an entire team
hallie ledbetter joins the show you know
her from golf digest and golf tv as a
host and producer
and hallie you're an accomplished
collegiate player yourself i know you
played college golf
colin played college golf four years at
cal and all american all four years
and not a lot of players on the pga or
lpga
always go and play collegiate golf so
how do you think
no collins time playing a cal prepared
him for this moment
yeah you know college golf i will say
you know golf is one of those sports
where it's like a gymnastics or a
swimming
if you go to college as a gymnast or a
swimmer
you generally you don't have any
aspirations of turning professional or
golf golf is just such is one of those
games where i mean you saw
uh phil mickelson you won 50 years old
so you can play
really at any age in college if you are
not winning
consistently winning every junior golf
tournament that you play in
you are silly not to go to college
because the competition
is so incredible in college a lot of
collegiate players even get
invites into professional events so
there's no sort of you know oh if i if i
go to college am i losing time
it's one of those things that hey let me
go give it a go if you happen to
actually absolutely be crushing college
golf you can leave i mean look at tiger
he went
for a year to stanford and he actually
said it was his biggest regret not
finishing at stanford so
i think golf is one of those really
unique sports where going to college can
actually work in your favor like it did
here for colin
now hallie t.j jefferson here grew up
loving colin morikawa
he affectionately refers to him as the
mechanic because of his crafty skills
around
the chevy chase country club where he
learned how to play so i know he's
he's all in but for the casual golf fan
for the gal fan who maybe isn't so
familiar with what colin's doing or
what's going on in the scene right now
how does his emergence help you think
bring in
some of the casual fans not like tj oh
yeah well colin first of all i mentioned
earlier just the
nicest guy and also listen i've been in
golf
um for my entire life really and it's
it's very rare to see somebody who's so
personable and has so much personality
like i mean you got to phil mickelson
for example but i don't know if you guys
caught
i'm sure he did his acceptance speech
yesterday for him to go to the crowd
like how is everybody doing and then
immediately thank
the you know congratulate the low
amateur he's just
he's just such a star he's got that star
power
and he's so young which is incredible
you know a lot of times those people
are you know sports stars kind of grow
into that and then they get comfortable
in the spotlight and then they come out
of the shell
come out of their shell but colin he's
out there he's ready to go and
he's just he's just such a wonderful guy
i also i saw on twitter was
kind of um you know floating around a
picture of colin
uh a few weeks ago in the memorial
playing with a yardage book that had the
pride flag on it so he's very
progressive he's very open he wants to
grow the game to different uh different
demographics
he's just he's just a really great guy
and i'm so so excited to see
um what he's going to continue to
accomplish holly ledbetter joins the
show she's gone from the evian
championship over in france you know of
course from golf digest ben line's in
for rich on the rich eisen show how you
had a great video
that really broke down the dechambeau
and kepca rivalry this bryson brooks
thing that's taken the golf world by
storm
uh for the for the passive golf fan not
tj but for the passive golf fan
break down to sort of this whole brooks
bryson thing and is it good for golf as
they head into the ryder cup
you know it the brooks bryson thing i
do believe is good for golf i do think
it's a little overplayed so it kind of
started out i'll sort of just
you know touch on a few points in that
video that you just mentioned done
so apparently brook said that
they had an agreement and bryson broke
it
for what that agreement is we aren't
quite sure so that's
what sort of started the you know
animosity
if you will between them and then things
just got you know
progressively worse you know there are
little quips here and there whether it
was brooks not seeing a single shot of
bryson dewitt's open victory and then
there was the twitch stream
thing that bryson said about it about
you know how many
majors that that that brooks had won
and then it escalated to where um brooks
was giving an interview a few weeks back
and bryson walked by and muttered
something there it's sort of um unclear
exactly what it was
but something i i believe brook said
something along the line about
something about putting and bryson said
you just got to put a good role in it or
something like that
but brooks rolled his eyes as bryson
walked by
um that footage was not supposed to air
but someone linked it on social
and it sort of blew up so i think
initially
we all kind of suspected that there were
um maybe not the best relationship
between the two
but that really confirmed everyone's
suspicions
um but i think it's good i think it's
good to have a little rivalry i do
think that that it is um
you know it is real a lot of people also
sort of
think that maybe they're sort of you
know making this up for the player
impact program which is that program
that pga tour put in place to really
encourage players to you know be a
little bit more active on social media
and get their name out there
i think that they might be playing it up
for that purpose
you know there's 40 million dollars up
for grabs
so they might be playing it up for that
purpose but i do think that you know
that they really don't like each other
and i think it's fine for golf i mean i
can be a little overplayed and i think
you know there's certain times when it's
like oh my goodness guys let's just give
it a rest
but overall i think it's good i think
it's good for our sport to have a little
bit of drama
getting back to colin and what he was
able to accomplish this weekend
you know we often halley are introduced
to young stars in golf and being told oh
this is the next guys the next tiger
this is what the sport needs and what's
sort of the next challenge for him
as you look forward uh to what he does
now that he's a two-time champion
you know i think he's just gonna have to
you know just continue
to to stick to his stick to his game you
know he's an incredible incredible
iron player he's come close over the the
last
few weeks i think the scottish open
didn't go that great for him
but he just needs to stick to his game i
mean he he's got a great coach in rick
sessinghouse
rick um i spent a lot of time well i
spent a lot of time on social media the
last few days but rick sessinghouse
tweeted yesterday that colin
is just just sort of like the perfect
player in terms of he looks at
everything as a challenge and he treats
the game with
with honor and i think you know a lot of
these young players like i mentioned
before have a problem
once they get in the spotlight because
they don't know how to handle it but
colin clearly knows how to handle it he
was kind of born for this
so i think he just has to you know stick
to the process and i think this guy has
a lot a lot of major wins in the future
for him
holly ledbetter joins the show from golf
digest of course ben line's in for rich
this is the rich eisen show and
you know tj and i were talking about
this before the show started about how
golf is having this new moment howie
this new energy around the game from new
brands
you see it on people's shoe choices from
air jordans and
you know exclusive nikes you're seeing
off-whites on the tour
how do you describe sort of the new golf
energy that's taken
taking place within the game and is it
seeping into
the lpga and pga tours yeah i think it's
awesome it i mean it really is
what golf needs i think it's i it's kind
of funny when
you know i i've been in golf for a
really long time and when people kind of
you know get get upset about the fact
that we're the people wearing hoodies on
the course
or joggers on the course i'm like how do
you guys expect to grow the game like we
have to evolve
we have to you know push forward and
that includes our fashion choices it's
not
just going to be chinos and and polo
shirts all the time and
that is a turn off for some people to
play golf and if we want to stay
relevant and continue to grow the game
we need to do that to attract this
younger generation and it's definitely
definitely showing up
um on the tours you you look i mean i'm
sure out here this week
there will be some some really cool
fashion choices like you mentioned the
nikes the people wearing air maxes and
jordans
and then you look on the tour and a lot
of joggers a lot of hoodies
um yeah i think it's great for golf and
it's honestly what we need to do to
continue to grow we really do need to
change the perception of the sport and
fashion is a way to do that whether
people like it or not
the the energy around the sport is
palpable right now but it's such an
interesting time historically
uh in the sport because of this
unprecedented run we've had of
this condensed major schedule you had
the tour changing some stuff around and
then of course the global pandemic now
we've had what six majors
in a very short amount of time collins
won two of them
how do you think history will look at
this run of majors in the world of
basketball some people say the bubble is
an asterisk some people say the dodgers
didn't really win the world series
whatever it is in other sports how does
how does golf kind of participate in the
world changing conversation
well i mean i definitely think that it
needs to be noted that
these these championships were held in
an unprecedented time it's different
playing
and not for a fan like it just is that
that being said
the other players are doing that as well
so it's not like a certain player has an
advantage or a disadvantage over the
other it's still a major championship on
a major championship
course there are just no fans and some
players are better at handling that than
others
some players you know there's maybe a
lack of pressure if you're a young gun
out there and you've never played in
front of huge major championship crowd
that probably works in your advantage
if you are if you've been out there for
a while and you get a lot of energy i
know ricky fowler talked about
getting energy from the fans then that
works at a disadvantage so
i mean it factors are different for
everybody i don't think
that it is an asterisk in the sense that
it doesn't count or it's not as
impressive because it is
um i went to the the masters in november
during um during the pandemic and it was
just a
wild experience to have no fans out
there
i am grateful that i got to experience
augusta that way
would i want that to happen again
absolutely not because there's just
something
incredible about having fans at the
masters or really
any tournament so yeah i think that
there's an asterisk but it doesn't
necessarily take away from the wins at
all
my favorite tony fenow is knocking on
the door i finished the top 15
uh showing across the pond what's going
on with tony and
talk to me a little bit about his star
power uh
tony is so close you know he's he's one
won that one event tony is just is
another
you know kind of similar to colin murray
college it's very humble
very down to earth hard worker uh my dad
actually used to work with him so
um i kind of grew up around tony and he
you know it's he's gonna break through
eventually he's he's gonna
i mean i'm gonna say i've been breaking
a right to me of his of his
uh accident that he had that par three
condos at the masters but that's an
example of tony i mean they turned that
into a nike commercial that was
hilarious
so you know tony he's gonna get there i
have faith in tony
i think you know it's only a matter of
time he's putting himself in the
position
and and tony tony final will win
a big golf tournament one of these days
hallie ledbetter joins the show golf
digest golf tv ben lines in for rich on
the rich eisen show
and i would imagine hallie being a lead
better working in golf
it's kind of like being a doctor if
you're at a dinner party where someone
says hey i know you're a doctor but uh
can you check
can can you tell me about what's going
on with my shoulder or hey what's going
on if uh if i can't sleep at night you
know people try to get that free medical
advice
so being that you're led better in the
golf world are people coming up to you
constantly and saying
hey what can i do with my swing or
what's one golf tip i need to
work on my game you know it's funny they
are
ben and i don't know if they think that
like the golf
golf instruction is genetic or what but
i am not the person to ask if you were
i guess semi good player or you need me
to like look at something if you're like
hey
my swing it's a little close at the top
can you check it out like absolutely
but if you just want me to come out and
like give you some advice i am
not the person but i i if golf
instruction is a gene
my two brothers have gotten it so it
must be a male gene because they are
fantastic golf instructors
but me it just it just did not it just
did not pass through the family to me
last last thing here on colin um
do you think that his hardcore fans
like like tj and and all the people who
grew up watching him play
uh all those years in glendale like do
you think they're satisfied or do they
want more is he chasing something
oh i think they want more i think this
is riling people up all the colin fans
you know that not to say that his first
you know first major a lot of people win
one major and then it's like oh okay
cool they want a major but this guy is
going to be around for a while so i
think this is firing up more call of
fans and
they're just they're going to expect
colin to contend like from here on out
but that's what we thought about rory
and it's been seven years now since
roy's won a major and i feel like we
often get introduced to these young
stars in golf and they say this is the
guy this is the next one
and they kind of flame out so can you
compare what are your thoughts on
where rory is at with his game right now
you know
he said the other day like oh if you
wanna if you want a guy to shoot even
for a major i'm your man i mean
he just he has the talent it's there but
he just can't
seem to like put you know put those
rounds together consistently so
i'm not a hundred percent sure what's
going on with him i'm a big rory fan
i think he's great and obviously
incredibly talented i mean
what a golf swing i could sit there and
watch it for hours but
yeah i'm not i i right now i put my
money on colin over over rory to win a
major for sure
well hallie we appreciate you checking
in from from over at the avion
championship
enjoy france is the best excuse for
missing a tee time i've
ever gotten from anybody this past week
we'll reschedule we will reschedule that
yeah i look forward to playing with you
when you get back safe travels thanks
for checking in
awesome thanks guys so much ali
ledbetter from golf digest joins the
show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here